Hi, welcome back. In this session, which
is going to be my final session on
trading and information, I want to go
past earnings reports. It is true that
earnings reports are the most common way
in which companies interact with public
markets. But there are other things that
can happen to companies. There can be
acquisitions that they announce. There
can be management changes. There can be
stock splits. So while we can't cover
all of these announcements, I want to
focus on a subset of them and talk about
how markets behave around these
announcements and whether there's a way
in which you and I as investors can take
advantage of the market response. So
let's start with acquisitions. For many
companies, acquisitions are the biggest
events that they announce because they
have they can have huge consequence for
the company. a an acquisition could
double the size of a company and often
you're paying far more than you've spent
on traditional capital expenditures for
the last decade. So let's start with a
graph that I think captures the essence
of who wins and who loses in
acquisitions. Remember when you have an
acquisition or a merger there are two
players. There's the acquiring firm and
there's the target firm. And in this
graph, we look on average across all
acquirers and across all targets, what
happens to the stock price of these
firms around the date of the
acquisition. So day zero is the day that
the world knows there's going to be a
merger or an acquisition.
Let's start with the obvious conclusion.
If there's a winner in this game, it's
definitely not the acquiring firm, it's
a target firm. the target firm stock
price jumps 15 20% around the
acquisition. We'll talk about what that
jump looks like across firms and why it
might be great at some targets and on
others but clearly target firms. Staying
with target firms though notice that
even before the acquisition is announced
the price starts to drift. That sounds
familiar right? You saw that with
earnings reports the drift in the price
before the positive earnings report or
the negative earnings report. Clearly
somebody is using that information about
an acquisition to trade ahead of the
announcement. So acquiring firms, their
target firms are the clear winners. What
about acquiring firms?
Looking across all acquiring firms much
more difficult to find an effect and
there's an effect at least over time.
It's close to zero in the announcement
date. But if you track in the days after
it's negative. So there are collective
winners and losers here. The winners are
the target firms. The losers the
acquiring firms. Let's focus on the
acquiring firms and see what we can
learn about target and acquiring firms
from looking across across different
kinds of acquisitions. This is from a
study that looked at hostile versus
friendly mergers. Hostile merger, the
target firm does not want to be taken
over. The acquiring firm thrusts itself
on the target firm. In a friendly
merger, both sides want it to happen. It
also looks at tender offers versus
mergers, cash versus stock, and hostile
versus friendly. Let's start with the
easiest differentiation here. Target
firms in hostile acquisitions do much
better than target firms in friendly
mergers. Target firms where the payment
is in cash do much better than target
firms where the payment is in stock. and
target firms where the acquisition
happens through a tender offer do better
than target firms where that's not the
case. So the next merger announcement
you see you might want to look at hey
what kind of merger is it a tender offer
traditional merger hostile or friendly
cash versus stock because the price
effect on target firms varies depending
on the merger.
Now looking at the bidding firm itself
the evidence has been mixed. The early
studies seem to suggest that even
bidding firm shareholders get some
benefits. You can talk about synergy and
other benefits you get from mergers. But
over time those excess returns have
drifted down. In fact, if you look at
the this century alone, the excess
returns to bidding firms has gone to
pretty much zero. On average across all
bidding firms, there seems to be no
excess returns. If you're a shareholder
in a bidding firm does an acquisition,
you make close to nothing from that
acquisition. And that's if you're lucky
because in about half of all bidding
firms, the stock price goes down. There
are negative excess returns around the
announcement. You know what the market's
telling you, right? The market's telling
you you're doing an acquisition if
you're the bidding firm and you're
paying too much. That in effect, the
target firm is getting 100% of the
benefits, if any, from the merger plus
more. So from the bidding firm
perspective, there doesn't seem to be
much you can do as an investor to make
money. Perhaps in the in some cases, you
might even make money by selling short
on bidding firms if they overpay. If
it's a kind of acquisition where the
overpayment is large.
If you look at why markets are so down
on bidding firms, it's perhaps because
if you track mergers after the fact, the
years after, and you look at how that
merger did in terms of delivering the
benefits were promised, most mergers
don't pass basic financial tests. What's
the most basic one? When you take a
project as a company, one of the first
questions you ask is, do I earn more
than my cost of capital? Do I have a
positive net present value? And it looks
like a lot of mergers don't pass that
test. You pay 5 billion for a target
firm. You need to generate more than 5
billion in value to cover that price.
Most mergers don't seem to do that. And
second, most mergers are sold in the
notion that if you do this, you're going
to do better than your peer group. Have
higher margins, higher profitability,
higher growth. And many mergers fail the
test. So a McKenzie study looking at
acquisition programs concluded that most
mergers don't pass those financial
tests. In most mergers, if you track the
excess returns in the long term, not
just in the days after the merger. In
many mergers, 60% of transactions earned
returns less than the cost of capital.
23% earn negative excess return. Only
23% earned excess returns. 77% are
negative excess returns.
And that magical word synergy that you
see thrown around a lot in mergers, a
KPMG study looked at synergy
specifically. And in the most expensive
deals, it concluded that only 17%
created synergy. There was value added
because remember the essence of synergy
is two companies come together and the
combined company is worth more than the
two individual companies. It's true in
only about one sixth of all mergers and
83% of the time the merger was either
value neutral. It was a zero sum game or
53% actually destroyed value. The two
companies coming together were actually
worth less than the two companies
standing alone. And here's the ultimate
evidence that most mergers don't work.
If you track merges after the years
after a surprisingly large number get
get reversed within uh 6 months within a
year within two years and if you track
it over longer periods that number rises
to close to half of all mergers are
reversed within five or 10 years of the
merger. The admission from the acquiring
firm that the promises were not
delivered. So here's the bottom line.
When mergers get announced, there is an
effect. The target company stock price
tends to go up. The bidding company
stock price doesn't do much. In fact, it
often drops reflecting the market's
pres, you know, assumption that this
merger is not going to create value for
the shareholders of the acquiring firm.
And if you track the mergers the years
after, you can see why. In many mergers,
synergy that's promised is not
delivered. the performance, the
profitability of the combined firm
doesn't measure up to what people sold
you at the time of the merger. So let's
think as investors, is there something
we can do to make money around this
acquisition process?
The most lucrative, of course, is invest
in a target firm before the acquisition
announcement. That'll require either
inside information, which is illegal, or
finding a way to predict which companies
going to be targeting acquisitions. And
I'll give you a couple of ways you might
be able to do it. That's the most
lucrative because then you get on the
ground floor for target firms, the
acquisition gets announced, you get that
30, 40, 50% jump in price. You can
invest neither the target or the
acquiring firm after the acquisition is
announced because there is this period
where the deal is still being worked
out. There's a chance it might fall
through, but the deal is being worked
out, but there's a price drift and
you're taking advantage of that price
drift. It's called merger arbitrage.
It's really not arbitrage but
speculation around the merger. And
finally, you can wait till the merger is
done and invest in companies which you
think have done good mergers. Remember
what the mergers are going to create
value with synergy. And a good merger
requires that that value create is
greater than the premium paid for the
acquisition and sell short in the
companies which overpay on acquisitions.
It's a pure post announcement strategy.
So let's look at how you might be able
to forecast which company's going to be
targeted in mergers. Research has looked
at target firms especially in hostile
takeovers where remember the bit the
price jump is greatest. And here's what
you see as a typical target firm. It has
underperformed other stocks in the
sector. It's less profitable than other
firms in the in that grouping. It has a
much lower insider stockholding and it
trades at a lower price to book ratio.
So these are not a typical target firm
is a badly performing company. The
market is turned down in the company. So
you know what you could do? You could
take an industry group and look for the
worst performers.
The worst performers that are trading at
the lowest prices. You can invest in
those companies and hope and pray that
they get targeted. Are you going to be
right 100% of the time? Of course not.
But even if you're right 20% of the
time, one in five of your companies gets
targeted, the money you're going to make
on those acquisitions is going to cover
the cost of the other four.
So you're basically estimating which
firms are potentially good target firms.
A more sophisticated technique is called
a probit which is a statistical
technique for estimating the probability
of getting taken over using observable
data such as you know under
profitability inside a holding. So
you're basically taking what you learned
from research putting it through a
statistical technique and then investing
in companies the pro but the probit
suggests that the probability of being
taken over is higher. So acquisitions
are a noisy process. We've learned a lot
from looking at acquisitions in the past
and perhaps as investors we can take
advantage of what we've learned to make
money off acquisitions.
Now in terms of post announcement
trading it's tougher because it's a
longerterm strategy and you're looking
for acquisitions where the acquiring
firm in fact has got a good deal right
because that's the only firm you can
invest in postacquisition.
So remember the likelihood of success
for mergers is greater in hostile
acquisitions of course friendly. It's
greater when you do mergers of like
businesses because where you have cost
savings and you go for growth and
potential synergies.
And it's greater where you have firms
where companies actually plan for
synergy before they're done. And finally
and this might be a potential value
creating strategy if you're an investor.
The chance of success rem is greater
when you acquire small private companies
and you pay a premium over what that
owner of the private company thinks a
business is worth but less than you
would have in a public market. Now the
rollup strategy is one example of this
where companies are created by rolling
up small private businesses and there's
been a history of success there and
maybe as an investor you can latch on.
That's the acquisition process and
potential ways of making money on it.
Let's look at a few other information
announcements in passing and see what we
can learn from from market reaction.
Stock splits. What's a stock split? It's
the most cosmetic of all corporate
actions. Right? You take a share, you
split into two shares. Nothing changes
about the operations. By itself, a stock
split should have no effect on value,
but does seem to affect prices. A stock
splits on average tend to see stock
prices go up. And you can tell a
signaling story. Only good companies
split their stocks. The fact that you're
splitting your stock must suggest you
think good things are going to happen.
So on average, stock splits
go with higher prices. But that price
effect happens before the stock split.
Most companies split their stock after
they've had an extended price run up. So
if you go out and buy a stock after a
stock split, there seem to be nothing
much left on the table for you. In fact,
if nothing else, you could argue that
stock splits increase your transactions
cost because remember we said bid ass
spreads as a percent of price are higher
at lower price stocks. So stock splits
are a cosmetic event not surprisingly
it's very difficult to think of ways of
making money of stock splits or stock
dividends. What about dividend changes
here? It's a tougher call because
companies do, you know, we talked about
this earlier in the context of sticky
dividends are reluctant to change
dividends and when they do, they're far
more likely to increase dividends and
decrease them. And when a company
changes dividends, there's information
that's conveyed to the market. When you
have a dividend decrease, the stock
price tends to drop. And this is around
the announcement because remember the
board gets together, announces dividends
will be higher, lower, stay the same.
So, if there's a dividend cut, stock
prices tend to drop by about 4.6% on
average. When dividends are increased,
stock prices tend to go up, but only
about 1%. That sounds asymmetric, right?
That a dividend increase has a much
smaller positive impact than a dividend
decrease
has in terms of lowering prices. And the
explanation for that is in the in in
what you found when you looked at
dividend changes over time that
companies are far more likely to
increase dividends and decrease
dividends. So when you see a dividend
cut, it's much bigger bad news than when
you see a dividend increase. But on
average at least, there's a price.
But if you track these dividend changes
over time, it turns out that dividend
changes have become less informative
over time. What am I talking about? This
actually looks at that effect of a
dividend increase or a decrease over
time, but then it breaks it down by sub
periods. In 1962 and 74, dividend
changes were pretty informative. That's
what you saw in that study that I just
showed you. If you update that study to
75 through 87, dividend increases have
become a slightly less positive and
dividend decreases much less negative.
And by the time you get to 1988 through
2000 and I'll wage if you track this up
through 2024 that the effects have
decreased. Dividend changes have become
much less informative. You're saying
why? Because the information we have on
companies has become richer. We have so
much more data on companies. We don't
have to wait for a dividend cut to know
that a company's in trouble. And the
market seems to be reflecting it. So
dividend changes convey information,
yes, but they convey less information
than they used to.
So let's look at information trading in
general. Look at what will determine
whether you can succeed as a trading and
information. First, you got to be
specific about the information you're
going to trade on because that's the
point at which you got to trade and you
got to invest in an information system
that delivers that information to you
about the event instantaneously. So
you're going to trade an earnings
report. You need to know when that
earnings report comes out and what it
contains almost immediately. Even 15 or
20 minutes lag. If you have a lag of 15
or it might be too much by then the
price might already fully reflect it.
You need to execute quickly. The problem
with so much information coming out
after the close of trading is by the
time you get a chance to trade the next
morning, the price impact might be fully
in there. You got to keep a lid on
transactions cost because you're going
to be trading a lot more than somebody
who buys stock and holds it for the next
5 years. But since you need to trade
quickly and keep cost low, it's going to
be it's going to be it's going to be a
challenge to keep that balance. And if
you do trade on information, let's say
you buy on an earnings report which is
much better than expected, hoping to
gain from the drift, you need to know
when to get out because that drift
doesn't last forever. It might be for a
day. It might be for a week. You need to
know when to sell. Trading information
is tricky and it's getting trickier in a
world where it's so much easier to trade
and information is so much more
accessible. I'll wage that where people
who made money on earnings reports two
decades ago, three decades ago are not
able to do it anymore because the
process is speeded up and compressed.
But if you decide to embark down this
route, I wish you the best. Thank you
very much for listening. And I hope you
found the session useful.